[Musique]
on l'a appelé la malédiction de la
vengeance des Pharaons contre les aventuriers
qui ont dérangé les tombeaux sacrés des
pyramides 1699 un navire polonais transportant deux
momies est hanté par des visions spectrales
et une tempête brutale 1803 pour les
membres de l'expédition entrent dans la pyramide de khafre pour ne jamais
émerger 1922 Toutankhamon  la tombe est ouverte
et une série de morts horribles frappe
l'équipe de fouilles pendant les 91 prochaines
années aucune autre tombe n'est dérangée dites de
ne pas l'ouvrir ouais dites-leur de les
retenir jusqu'à maintenant
alors qu'est-il arrivé à un air toxique que l'on
trouve généralement dans les grottes et  structures de tombes qui
ont été scellées comme vous pouvez le voir la
pyramide derrière moi n'a que trois côtés
pas quatre comme la pyramide de Gizeh regardez
la taille de cette chose vous dites que nous
ne pouvons pas y entrer c'est la trouvaille
du siècle
vous '  tu es fou penses-tu que je n'y vais pas
reste près et ne touche à
rien
regarde ce qui est mauvais ces sculptures
racontent une histoire c'est un avertissement avertissement
football nous devons reculer  d'ici un
à la fois c'est un labyrinthe construit dans
le but d'empêcher tout ce qui est à l'
intérieur de vous échapper